A shepherd - boy looked after the sheep belonging to the people of the village.
One day, he cried, "Wolf! Wolf!"
Hearing him, the villagers ran to help him drive away the wolf.
However, when they reached him, there was no wolf to be seen.
The boy thought it was very funny.
"You weren't quick enough," he said to them.
"The wolf has run away."
Thinking he was very clever, a few days later, he shouted, "Wolf!" again.
Again, the villagers came to help him, and again he said,...
..."You weren't quick enough. The wolf has run away."
The angry villagers went back to their work in the village.
A week later, the boy shouted, "Wolf!" again,...
...but the villagers did not believe him.
However, this time, there really was a wolf...
...and it killed all the sheep, because no one came to drive it away.